well if the problem with the raiders
winning games was because of their
defense las vegas made a move they think
will change all that sports director
chris matthews joins us with more on the
hiring of someone new
in charge of stopping other teams from
scoring chris that's right kirsten
everybody's crossing their fingers as
higher will be a good one las vegas
raiders hired
one of the most important coaching
positions on the team outside of gruden
perhaps hiring gus bradley
is the most important hire they'll make
bradley's journey to las vegas has taken
him from tampa bay with john gruden
to seattle where he helped build the
seahawks defense remember it was called
the legion of doom
he spent a few years as head coach in
jacksonville before landing in
los angeles with the chargers he's now
in las vegas
with a plan to get the raiders defense
turned around
but you know obviously it starts up you
need to be able to affect the
quarterback
you know when you look at stats year in
and year out they say you know if you
stop the run
you know if you're in the top five stop
the run does that give you a great
chance to make in the playoffs
but really the staff as consistent is
the ability to affect the quarterback
if you can affect the quarterback you
get a good chance to help your team
you know make it to that level that
you're all shooting for
don't feel bad if you've never heard or
seen bradley before
because apparently the raiders social
media team hadn't either
they first posted this picture of ken
wizzenhunt as the raiders new defensive
coordinator
then quickly moved to the correct
picture the two did work together in los
angeles there with the chargers bradley
is from the midwest a small town in
minnesota called
zabrota with a population of just 3 200
people
the city lists two prominent people in
that town charles beck who is the chief
artist of the dc comic super
book hero captain marvel and the other
defensive coordinator gus bradley